I want to talk about I mean we're
talking about hello Baba I think there's
something that I could have used when my
first son was born like nine years ago
what was what was the motivation behind
starting this well we live in Los
Angeles and we're crazy fortunate to be
overpaid so we had an unlimited budget
we had access to all these great
products that were plant-based and
organic and safe for the babies and we
started thinking you know it seems very
unfair that our relatives in Michigan
don't have access to this or it's too
expensive and we thought while we're in
a position to kind of start a company
with the economy of scale that would
allow these to be really affordable and
be the exact same quality level and
safety level is all the products that we
were buying we like to say it's your
mom's standards at your dad's prices so
they're organic wherever they can be and
we we have created you know with the
technology we have now an awesome diaper
that's mostly plant-based and uses some
traditional materials but it has in my
opinion the softest fit possible it is
the most absorbent we change the
patterns every three months to try to
keep it fun and we really just wanted to
create an accessible community for
parents to never have to choose between
their baby or their budget yeah that's
very cool and even when you go on the
website it's it's very accessible
there's great humor involved in writing
the write-ups about the products is that
a big part of like crafting the hello
Bell oh I guess experience yeah we we
like being irreverent we think that you
know we have opinions on a lot of topics
but we also have a sense of humor about
ourselves and we hate feeling preached
to nor do we want to preach to anybody
so you know we both have like different
triggers as people and it's fun to
create a company looking out for all the
things that would you know what we
wanted to do better like when I was
buying you know baby stuff it was all
like it was like a very pale pink or a
white bottle and I was looking at my
nursery going my nursery is covered in
urine and avocado this bottle looks very
out of place so let's make sure that the
bottle is fun
and let's make sure we're putting the
word butt on the packaging because
diapers are for your butt
let's not pretend they're not catchers
you know and let's there's these wipes
are for boogers
and so we wanted to just kind of like
you know lift this veil on how sweet and
precious parenting has to be and be like
no it's the most beautiful thing but
it's also a freaking mess
yeah there's also a lot of uncertainty
and often times like guilt involved in
how you raise your baby and the products
that you buy and the things that you do
and I feel like you guys are really
addressing that with your approach well
yeah I think there was a there was an
article not too long ago about the
amount of time that 50s housewives spent
with their children versus modern-day
working mothers and that the modern-day
working mothers also spending more
quality time with their kids so yeah the
expectation we think has gotten quite
daunting and a lot of us are trying to
do this perfect and it can't be done
perfect so yeah then the more we can
kind of own many ways that were screwing
up we feel like it's comforting to other
people I have the same exact goal of
doing it and turning your kids into the
world and hoping that there is you know
fully formed as possible but it just
can't be done perfect it's all about
trying and what we want to create is a
shame free community like we gave away a
million diapers in the first year
because we wanted to say we're gonna put
four in this for-profit business we're
gonna put our money where our mouth is
we're gonna share we're gonna help
people who are in need and we're gonna
just create a place where we can all
laugh about this crazy existence that is
parenting yeah what does the parents
night in called about well so we we
hosted this thing we had and I think
you're referring to the camp hello Bello
where we yeah yeah and then we decided
to end it with a big box nah Lea that
was just for parents because anyone
who's been in quarantine with their kids
knows that it is you know between the
homeschool living nightmare no break no
chance recharge your patients
we put our kids in front of the TV when
we need a break I want to say that
publicly and let every parent know that
that is OK during a global pandemic we
did a third you know we did a month a
little over a month on hello bellow of
hello bellow camp where we hired hired
because we also thought it we should be
putting money into the community so we
hired yoga teachers out of work school
teachers chefs dog trainers - all do
like 30-minute sessions to teach kids
you could put your kid in front of
something educational and the final
night we hosted a parents night in and
we had some of our favorite people like
Josh GAD and Evan Rachel Wood and the
Native brothers performed and Pete Wentz
and we wanted to celebrate the parents
not just the kids that's awesome no
you're gonna have a celebration coming
up a big milestone birthday coming up
next month
Dax any big plans I live hourly in great
fear of not rising to the occasion I'm
right now cycled by fear section of the
process but I'm sure I'll start think
lever ideas soon especially because
quick on Father's Day in such a manner
that now the bar is so high it's it's
daunting yeah yeah you really can't
disappoint in this scenario Chris are
you the type to be very open and blunt
about what you would like for a birthday
like this or are you are you going to
just drop subtle hints no I'm very open
and honest and and most you know I don't
um I don't value material things as much
as I value time so I've already asked
for a few things I said I want like two
hours on my birthday where I can put my
book on tape in and just sit there just
sit my body down and not answer anyone's
questions not have to pour orange juice
for anyone but just listen to my book on
tape so I'm asking for solitude yeah
like I want a break from you on my
birthday I want to leave this family for
some period of time right now are you
two both looking forward to the business
of you know getting back on film and
working on film and TV projects really
settled into this whole thing of being
at home like you found a good groove
it's been really nice it's been
unexpected I think we both been really
busy over the last couple years
I certainly have so to have that much
time with the girls has been such a
blessing and with that said I do start
tomorrow back to top gear and I'm
thrilled to be going back to top gear
I am the opposite I feel like I've
worked my tail off the last 15 years and
I am so I do not want to go back to work
I am so happy at home I've taken up a
bunch of different hobbies and I'm
making a sweater for the last month and
a half is stunning it is stunning
hey we're doing this time at home so I
don't know you ready to go back to the
real world hope how far along the
processor are you like when can we
expect stuff about Gossip Girl is that
is that news coming anytime soon I well
gosh I don't know because my involvement
is obviously as the voice it's the it's
the secondary layer in editing right
they'll shoot the show and then they'll
edit it together and then a layer the vo
and so until they go back to work and
actually shoot the show I I'm just gonna
twiddle my thumbs waiting like the rest
of us yeah Dex I am an armchair II I'm
very calm about yeah yeah I'm excited
about hearing you and Monica know every
week I have the Blake Griffin one lined
up to listen to next who've you not
gotten yet who are you chasing that you
are like just so stoked to talk to you
or do you have a dream guest that you
haven't had a chance to book yet oh yeah
I have a bunch obviously Bill Murray I'd
love to talk to Donald Glover we've been
trying for two and half years Mindy
Kaling we want to talk to what's been
really really great and super flattering
is we generally can get all the experts
we want we keep getting just blown away
with the people that are willing to do
the show like we had Ebro max on last
week who is just
you know so many people want to talk to
him right now and to get two hours of
his time was just so flattering and
that's been the big surprise in thing
we're grateful for on the show is just
how many great professors and experts in
their field are willing to come out and
talk to us